IKAI LAN: Hi everybody.
Welcome to another edition of
Google Developers Live.
This is Apps Script.
My name is Ikai Lan.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Arun
Nagarajan here.
IKAI LAN: And we have a good
show for you guys today.
There's a lot of good
stuff coming up.
And before we get started, I
want to announce a few things.
First off, if you haven't yet
signed up for our Los Angeles
Hackathon, that's happening
in the middle of November.
It's happening in, I think,
what three weeks now?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah,
November 13.
IKAI LAN: Something like that.
Go to your favorite search
engine, whichever it may be,
and search for Apps Script
Hackathon, Los Angeles.
We still have some spots.
I'll be sending out reminder
notices on whatever channel I
have, be it Twitter,
G+, blog posts.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Everything.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
You start getting bombarded.
So we would love to
see you out there.
So definitely sign up.
And tell us what your dietary
preferences are, so we don't
get you something
you can't eat.
The second thing I wanted to
announce is that we've got a
very special Office Hours
happening next Tuesday.
It's actually less of an Office
Hours and more of a
live session.
We'll be having a guest from
the BigQuery team.
And we'll be talking about how
to use BigQuery in Apps Script
to do large-scale data analysis
and import it into
your various Apps properties.
So, we'll have a guest.
That's next Tuesday.
I believe it is at 4:30,
3:30, 4 o'clock.
Either way, I've
posted on the--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's
4:30, yeah.
IKAI LAN: I posted it
on the live sight.
So go to
developers.google.com/live.
And click on next Tuesday,
and you'll
see when that's happening.
So, hopefully, you'll be
able to join us then.
And, if not, as always, our
sessions are always recorded.
So you could watch
it later on.
So, Arun, I'm sorry.
I've been taking up all
this time speaking.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: No, no.
IKAI LAN: And Arun has had a lot
of cool stuff happening.
And why don't you tell
us about some of it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So I think I spoke about last
time, I've been really trying
to get engaged with the
community and go out to these
DevFests that have been going
on around the world.
I went to DC, presented there.
I also went to a Meetup here
locally in New York and
presented at the Twilio
user Meetup.
Talked about how SMS and phone
calls could be intercepted,
and kick off Apps Script
events and services.
IKAI LAN: And Twilio.
Tell us what that is for the
people in our audience.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So Twilio
is cloud-based
telecommunications.
So they're a pretty
cool company
based out of San Francisco.
Twilio is twilio.com.
Check it out.
It's pretty cool,
very affordable.
I think it's $0.01 to text
message, $0.01 a minute for a
phone call.
So very interesting things
that you can do.
Where, let's say, if you're
a school, if you're taking
attendance through a spreadsheet
through forms, you
can run an automated script
once a week and find the
students that are being tardy,
or skipping class, and notify
their parents proactively,
rather than waiting until the
teacher gets around
to that report.
So things like that.
So the fact that you can write
it all in JavaScript, call out
the RESTful services, with
authentication from Apps
Script, is, I think, a pretty
powerful combination.
IKAI LAN: And Twilio has
a bunch of things.
You can use it as an IVR system
for, you know when how
you call, hello, welcome to
movie ticket services.
Or they also have
text-to-speech if I'm not mistaken.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So you can actually have it
read out a blurb of text.
I forget how long the text can
be, but a paragraph or
something less.
You can have that be read out
by a woman with a British
accent or a man--
IKAI LAN: I didn't know
you could do that.
So not just robot.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you can
play mp3 files as well.
So it's actually kind of cool.
And that's one of the things
that I'm trying to really
engage with the community is.
The beauty of Apps Script a lot
of times is not just with
Google Apps, but to go out and
hook into other systems like
Salesforce.com, or Twilio,
or getting weather from a
third-party system.
So URL Fetch can be a really
powerful friend.
And it can do a lot of cool
things, especially because it
has the ability to do
authentication through
headers, OAuth 1 support.
And we're constantly looking
to make that all better.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And I'm also
going to continue my whirlwind
tour of trying to get
to meet as many
developers as possible.
So, this weekend, I'm going
to be at the SLC
camp here in New York.
SLC stands for Shared Learning
Collaborative.
And they're a nonprofit
organization that collects a
lot of anonymous data
about students,
and stats, and behavior.
And that data can be
used for mashups.
And you can hack together
interesting reports,
interesting analytics.
You can actually provide
information to teachers and
education administrators
proactively.
So it's sort of a Hackathon
where they're inviting
teachers, and students, and
also, in some cases,
developers.
And we're all coming
together to build
some interesting mashups.
And I'm hoping to build a lot
of interesting things with
Apps Script.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then
a couple more things.
So the weekend after is
24 Hours Of Good.
So that's also here
in New York.
It's actually 24hoursofgood.com.
If you're in New York, Seattle,
and San Francisco, I
think, are the events.
Or maybe it's LA.
But check it out.
I think it's really
quite good.
And we're actually going to be
there, and give a talk on Apps
Script, and encourage
people to the build
stuff on Apps Script.
And then I'll be at EDUCAUSE
in Denver.
That's for a couple of days.
And then I'll be with
you at the LA--
IKAI LAN: Yes.
Los Angeles Hackathon.
See, I'm going to plug that
as much as possible here.
Well, besides going to events,
you're also working with some
of our customers and some of
our users to solve some
problems they are having.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And it's been really exciting
to get to know our large
customers, large partners,
that are doing some very
interesting things, in some
cases, running into some
limits or some issues
that might not be
apparent and easy to solve.
So it's been quite good to get
on the phone with these
customers, do a Hangout,
and get to know them
a little bit better.
And one recent experience that
I think is a little worth
noting is a customer
deployed globally.
I think they had 40,000 or
50,000 users worldwide with a
lot of interesting use cases
around workflow.
So they wanted to be able to
come up with a document
approval workflow.
And email was going to be the
mechanism to notify when
something gets delegated to a
manager for approval, or when
something was approved or denied
back to the employee.
And with that many users, I'm
sure you're aware, there are
limits around how many emails
a single account can
send out per day.
I believe it's 2,000 for
a domain account.
So we came up with an
interesting mechanism where
they could use ScriptDb as sort
of a cue for emails to be
sent out, that the main
script would write to.
And then that shared library
with the access token to the
ScriptDb will get used by all
of these other worker
processes that run on a minute
trigger or five-minute
trigger, whatever makes sense,
spread out amongst multiple
different service accounts--
10, 15, 20, whatever
makes sense--
each of them that get the 2,000
mail limit per day.
And they can pick up those
emails, and send them out, and
say I've sent this email out,
and mark it checked, so that
some other agent doesn't
pick it up.
So, in this case, it happened
to be an interesting
work-around.
But, with the power of ScriptDb,
which allows you to
share this persisted state
across multiple accounts, and
then have something run on a
trigger, you can start to
build some interesting workflows
that, in some cases,
can help you get around things,
in some cases, help
you build something really
cool and exciting.
So if you're doing
things like that,
definitely shoot us a note.
I would love to hear
more about it.
And it helps us to really
understand where are those
limits, what are those things
that you're having trouble
with, and make sure we advocate
for you internally,
and build those capabilities
up.
IKAI LAN: Oh yeah.
I mean I think it's really
important for us to turn up
the limits.
I know I keep saying this,
but things are happening.
Alright?
You guys just have to believe
me on this one.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And it should be a process that
takes a little bit of
time, because your code, as
you know, are running on
Google servers.
So we can't just turn the
knob and walk away.
We have to really make sure
that it all makes sense.
And, obviously, we all
understand the
issues around it.
IKAI LAN: Alright.
So thank you, Arun.
So, normally, this is about the
time when we'd go over the
release notes.
But we haven't been pushing
on anything
that's externally visible.
So just stay tuned.
There's a lot of cool
stuff coming.
How'd you like to jump
on the Hangout?
Do you know if there's
anyone on right now?
Or, if not, we can start
with the questions.
And if anyone jumps on the
live hangout, we can--
Yes.
We've got a couple of folks.
Why don't say hi to
these guys first.
Hey guys.
BILL: Hey.
How are you doing?
IKAI LAN: Doing well.
How are you?
Bill, is that you?
BILL: Yeah.
That's me.
I'm at my secret hideout.
That's why the background
looks different.
IKAI LAN: I'm not in my
usual position here.
So I can't see the
Hangout screen.
But I'm just peaking
over when I can.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
We had some technical issues.
And we decided to put the
Hangout monitor on our right.
So, if you see me looking away
from the camera, I'm actually
looking at the folks
on Hangout.
So I apologize.
BILL: Cool.
Hi, Arun.
I don't think I've
met you yet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Nice
to meet you.
Is that Bill?
BILL: Yeah.
I got caught up on the last
couple that I missed.
So--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
BILL: Nice to meet you.
Welcome to the team.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank
you very much.
I got my official Developer
Relations hoodie.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So it's
welcome gift.
IKAI LAN: Those are great
hoodies, by the way.
They're super comfortable.
I was evangelizing for weeks
before I realized that these
guys didn't have them.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
There's one other gentleman
on the Hangout.
You don't have to say hi if
you're shy, but we just wanted
to say hi to you.
He's shy.
That's OK.
So, Bill, how are you?
BILL: Good.
I see that you answered the
one question I had on the
Moderator about the Google
Sites custom URL.
IKAI LAN: Why don't we answer
that for everyone that's not
looked at the Moderator.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think that's
officially the number one
requested bug fix of all time.
So we can't--
IKAI LAN: Within Apps Script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exactly,
within Apps Script.
We can't sweep that
one under the rug.
IKAI LAN: So I have good
news and bad news.
And the good news is that, yes,
we're working on this,
and it's on our radar.
And that I'd like to think that
a fix is coming out soon.
And, hopefully, a fix
is coming out soon.
But I don't have anything
to announce yet.
Just stay tuned.
BILL: OK.
So the bad news is
it is not yet.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
The bad news is not yet.
But for those people that aren't
familiar, the issue is
that when you want to create a
gadget and put this gadget on
the Sites page, and the Sites
page is mapped to a custom
domain, it won't work because of
various cross-domain issues
and authorization.
It's completely cross-domain,
if I'm not mistaken.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
It's completely to do with the
security and authentication.
Because we're serving the
scripts off of .Google.com, we
need to make extra sure
that it's sanitized.
And there's no cross-frame
communication going on.
So we've been in close touch
with our developers, and
engineers, and our security
analysts.
And we've explained to them how
important this is, and how
critical this is.
And, obviously, all this
information that's been--
including the ones in all
caps-- all the comments
do get passed on.
And we do review it and ensure
that it makes sense to fix,
and this one without a doubt.
IKAI LAN: I don't know if I'd
pass on the ones in all caps.
I do pass on the other ones.
No.
This is definitely a very
important issue.
It's a really bad experience.
People go ahead and create this
gadget, and you go to
custom domain, and the
gadget stops working.
So, hopefully, we'll have this
fixed for you very soon.
BILL: I think it's something,
just from the developer
community prospective, just
to know that it's
being worked on.
Because I recognize that is a
pretty serious security issue.
So I don't have any problem with
you guys doing a great
job building it right.
The important part was getting
an idea that it is actually
something that is actively
[NEW USER ENTERED HANGOUT]
being worked on.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: Yep.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Without
a doubt.
BILL: I did have one question
I didn't put in there not
related to that.
IKAI LAN: Sure.
BILL: I've been trying to
empirically find out how many
bits of things I can get in a
ScriptDb by stuffing it with a
known size.
So I've got a script that's
running, trying to figure--
IKAI LAN: There is
a specific limit.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
BILL: Yeah, 200 megabyte.
Right?
For the paid domain.
IKAI LAN: Oh, it's
up to 200, OK.
I was going to say it was 50.
BILL: A personal
account is 50.
A free Google Apps domain is
100, and a paid domain is 200.
IKAI LAN: Right.
BILL: So I want to know, with
200, how many objects is that?
That's in megabytes.
It's not in JSON objects.
So I've got a script that's
running right now that's
stuffing it.
And one of the interesting
things that I've found is
there seems to be a limit--
It takes a little while to get
objects into the database.
So I think it's going to take me
a while to actually get to
the upper limit.
Is there any bottlenecks
or anything?
I've tried the batch.
I've tried saving individual
objects.
I've tried saving
batch objects.
Can you give me any
insight into--
IKAI LAN: So, when you say that
there's a limit, you mean
that you're not able to push
things at a certain speed, or
that you'll put things
but they aren't
visible right away.
BILL: A certain number
of items.
Yeah.
So, first, I started by--
I just created a simple loop to
stuff a fixed-size object
into the ScriptDb and looped
through it a bunch of times.
And then I was like, okay,
that ran slow.
That's what I expected.
I put it into a batch
save process.
And it seems to go in about
at the same speed.
It seems to time out.
The fastest I was able to do
it was about 2,000 objects
before the script
would time out--
sorry, 4,000 objects before
it would time out.
It's just one key value
pair, not very big.
And so I just wondered if
there's some sort of limit.
It seems to be a little bit
slow in accepting objects,
even in the batch mode.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: In the batch
mode, you're only calling the
save batch function once?
BILL: Yes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you have an
array with about 4,000 or so
items, and then you call
save batch on those,
and it times out.
BILL: Yeah, at around
4,000 times.
So I just wondered if
there's something--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, time
out seems to be an odd
response for that.
IKAI LAN: It does
seem to me like
something that would happen.
But we just need to figure out
why it's doing that, why it's
stopping it at 4,000
objects or so.
So you're saying that when you
try with 4,000 objects in a
single call, that
it times out.
And if you try with more,
If you try with fewer,
it does not time out?
BILL: That's right.
IKAI LAN: OK.
BILL: And, I should mention,
the 4,000 was the highest I
was successfully able to do.
And it fluctuates with
the time of day.
Scripts run faster or slower
depending on the time of day.
Monday morning seems
to be a little bit
slower through the day.
But if you run it on Sunday,
at 3 AM, things
run a little faster.
And I assume that's just
Google's overall server load.
IKAI LAN: I can't speak
to that particularly.
I haven't seen that myself.
BILL: I've got customers that
notice that, in particular
times a day, scripts run
a lot slower than
other times of day.
And they're running with
big data sets.
They're running with
spreadsheets with 2,000 lines
of 40 columns, and things like
big, jumbo spreadsheets on
multiple spreadsheets.
And they notice a difference
in how fast scripts run
throughout the day.
IKAI LAN: I do have a theory.
But, again, I always
say this to Arun.
I have a theory.
It's backed by nothing, except
me making stuff up, which is
that if you doubled the size
of the objects, you would
probably stuff half the
number of objects
before it times out.
I'd be really curious.
Send me your scripts sometime.
I'd be really curious if it has
to do with the size of the
total objects or the number
of total objects.
Now, I can see a case either way
for why it would time out.
If it's the number, then
it's the overhead
of creating an object.
Whereas if it's just straight
up size, then maybe it just
has to do with the amount
of data that is being
pushed down the pipe.
BILL: Once I get a little
farther along--
I've got one script that's
running now.
And I've got a couple--
What I was going to do is run
it with an object of that
size, and then run it with an
object twice that size.
Because what I'm trying to do
is get a sense of how big of
an object, how many
objects can you
stuff, for 200 megabytes.
Just so I have some sense of how
big, and that was my goal.
And it's when I came up to this
writing speed was the new
interesting observation.
IKAI LAN: So shoot
me an email.
If you don't have my email
address, it's my first name
@Google.com.
BILL: OK.
IKAI LAN: So that's that your
challenging puzzle, to
decipher my email address.
It's not that hard.
It's plastered all over
the internet.
But shoot me an email with your
results, and I'd love to
dig at this for you.
Because I'm totally interested
in data stores.
Data stores just
rock my world.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Aren't
you writing a
blog post on ScriptDb?
IKAI LAN: It's eventually
happening.
Aren't you doing--
and I have to call him
out on something that
he's working on now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
A lot of things that
are not done yet.
IKAI LAN: So I heard someone
jump into the Hangout.
We just want to say hi.
You don't have to say hi back.
We just want to say hi to you.
If you do, we'd appreciate it.
Silence.
I need to find a new way of
doing that, a new way of--
MATT: Hey.
My name is Matt.
I'm actually a computer science
major at University of
Central Oklahoma.
I just wanted to jump in and
just observe the discussion.
IKAI LAN: Sure.
Did you say University
of Oklahoma?
MATT: I'm sorry?
IKAI LAN: Did you say University
of Oklahoma?
MATT: Central Oklahoma,
a little bit north.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
Yeah, just hang out and stay
as long as you want.
MATT: Yeah, thanks.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
So let's see.
What other questions
could we answer?
So here's a gentlemen that
would like to attach a
favicon, an ICO file, against
a web app built using UiApp.
IKAI LAN: So with UiApp, because
you can't change the
structure of a document, you're
not able to do that.
But when you're working with--
I think they're pronounced
"fave-i-cons." I don't know.
"Fav-i-cons, fave-i-cons."
Favicons.
If you're using HTML service,
you should be able to set it
using the link parameter.
Now, if Kaha is preventing you
from doing this, you should
let us know.
I don't see any way how this
would be harmful, so we would
want it whitelisted.
But you should be able to set
it inside the head element,
where you say link rel =
"fav-i-con," "fave-i-con," and
point to favicon.
Now, we can't host the
favicon for you.
But there are lots of places
where you can host it.
You could host it in
a Google Site.
You could host it in any kind of
hosting that's retrieval by
the public.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's actually a really
good point.
So I would like to know
if that works as well.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
What are my choices to back up
a Google Apps Script project.
I mean, saving my whole project
code on another place
with some automation.
Script files are not included
in Drive Sync, neither can
they be downloaded.
IKAI LAN: So one thing that I
do is I just make a copy of
the script itself.
So, in Drives, you could just
do this quickly and cheaply.
And this is one way that
I back things up.
Now, I understand what you're
saying, which is that how do
you back it up off site.
And there are a lot of reasons
why you would want to do that.
The are a lot of reasons
why I want to do that.
Our code review tools here at
Google, for instance, do not
work with Apps Script
directly.
Unfortunate, and we're working
on those guys.
But, for now, what we're going
to need to do, what I do, is I
take those files.
I save them to my local
file storage.
And I push them into
our source control.
So source control is another
feature that
we've heard asked for.
And, hopefully, we'll be able
to get that out as well.
But, for now, those are
your solutions.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
IKAI LAN: I don't know if
you do anything else.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: No.
I guess I just trust the
system in this one.
So there is a version
history built in.
So you can see what is usually
going into your file.
So that's part of the
system there itself.
And I just make it so that I
save versions as I need to for
bigger snapshots.
And I just assume that it's
going to be there the next
time I come in.
So I don't really download
it to my local
file system that often.
The Editor is quite good.
So I don't really need to go to
a different editor to edit
that JavaScript.
IKAI LAN: One thing about
versions though is that it's
not a version of the code that
you can go back to and edit.
And so, for instance, you can't
save a version six and a
version seven.
And your version seven
is terrible.
So you go back to version six.
You throw away version seven.
So I do understand the
need for this.
But, in those cases, if I have a
very important point, that's
when I usually fork
the script.
And it's not the best
solution, but it
works really well.
And search will work.
And it'll show up
in your drive.
It won't show up on your local
hard drive, but it's something
that I've been doing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: When you say
fork a script, you mean file,
make a copy.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
File, make a copy.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I just want to
make sure, terminology-wise.
IKAI LAN: I've been bugging
the team for
a Apps Script app.
You know how you have
spreadsheet app and Docs list.
So that I can actually
write scripts
that manipulate scripts.
But I start to blow too many
minds when I suggest it.
So I'm just wondering, anyone
else on the Hangout, if you
guys have any practices
you guys use
for backing up scripts.
Bill?
BILL: No.
I trust Google.
I'm a Google Apps reseller
as well.
So I spend all day selling
people on why Google has got a
great storage right there.
So I do run into that problem
when I have a version.
You know I've saved a version,
and I want to go back.
So I try not to make mistakes.
But, pretty much, I do
the same as you.
If I really want to secure
a version, I fork it.
One interesting tool you might
want to pass along is, I just
found the JSLint,
the web page.
And I've been pasting my
Apps Script into it.
And that's helped a little
bit improve my code
discipline, if you will.
And I was thinking, like you,
I should write a script that
writes scripts, or
reviews scripts.
So it'd be nice if we
could have a script
access another script.
And we could build our own
JSLint, or if you want to
build that in for us,
into the Editor.
There's a bit of one
in the IDE now.
IKAI LAN: I think one of the
limitations, though, that we
run into, is that because an
Apps Script is not treated as
a set of files and drive,
which is complicated.
If it were, for instance, we
could write a drive app that
downloads it, lints it, pushes
it into the source controller,
pushes it into your
code review tool.
I mean part of me wonders.
It's good that we provide all
of this functionality.
But there's that line we draw
between what should we
provide, and what should we just
build on what exists now.
Source control has
so many people--
I'm sorry?
BILL: I was just going to say
that part of the value in Apps
Script is the simplicity of it.
Right?
IKAI LAN: Right.
BILL: It's not meant
to do everything.
So yeah, I agree.
Adding features adds
complexity.
And that actually raises
the bar to new
developers using it.
IKAI LAN: But what new features
can we add such that
if you were an advanced
developer, or an experienced
developer, and you have a
specific tooling need.
You should be able
to do workflow on
your Docs and email.
But you also should be able to
do workflow on your apps
themselves.
BILL: Yeah.
Is there a particular reason
why they're not saved as an
actual file?
Because they are simply
just a text file.
Right?
And they are somewhere.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, they
are certainly somewhere.
IKAI LAN: They are somewhere.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Up until
recently, I think this spring
is when you could create
standalone scripts.
Up until then, they were
container bound.
IKAI LAN: Right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So the
container-bound scripts,
imagine if all of a sudden they
just started showing up
in your drive.
I think that might be a little
alarming for some folks.
Because a single spreadsheet
might have four, five, six
scripts, depending on the events
that you may tie into.
So that's one of the reasons,
up until recently, we didn't
have this concept of a project,
that's standalone
that's on your drive.
It becomes more of a
possibility now.
Because you've specifically
said this is a standalone
container, rather than bound
to another container.
So it becomes more reasonable,
I guess, but not something
that we've actively
considered.
BILL: It was interesting.
I have someone that I'm
teaching Apps Script.
And he is a 20-year coder.
And it took a little while in
the first session to explain.
This was just back in the
spring, before they had the
standalone.
It took a little bit of a
discussion about the idea of a
spreadsheet as a container, or
as a site as a container.
It took a little bit of time to
say, well, no, it doesn't
really exist anywhere, except
it's attached to something.
IKAI LAN: Right.
I wonder if there are ways
we can improve the Ui.
For instance, now that
you have the
standalone script editor.
For instance, you have a
spreadsheet-bound Ui.
There should be some indicator,
like, hey, here's
how you get back to the
original spreadsheet.
And there are things
that we do now--
BILL: That's in the
issue tracker.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
I believe it.
And I'm wondering what
the right thing
for us do there is.
So let's move on to
something else.
There's a couple of questions,
which I've posted comments on.
So let's see.
I'll let you pick who the
winning questions are.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's
see here.
So this one is the error
messages around your script
has recently failed to
finish successfully.
So this must be maybe they
registered for a trigger.
You've already responded
to this one?
IKAI LAN: I've tried to.
So the question is your script
not found has recently failed
to finish successfully.
Now, I'm pretty sure that
we finished dealing
with orphaned script.
But there probably are
a few orphaned
script out there somewhere.
So what you'll want to do is
open up Script Editor.
This is at script.google.com.
And go to, I think, it's tools,
all of my triggers, and
you'll see if anything
is running.
Because I know I've solved this
for someone, where if you
go there, you'll say, oh, I
have these extra triggers.
Delete, delete, delete.
It'll do what you need to do.
And--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
a good point.
IKAI LAN: --you'll close
this thing down.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
a good point.
Let's see here.
Links to stack overflow.
I won't click on that for now.
IKAI LAN: So the question is
about can we clarify quotas.
And we're running out
of time, so we won't
be able to do this.
But that is a very
good question.
The question is about which
quotas are being
used in a web app.
And it's very confusing, because
sometimes you use
ScriptDb quota, which
is the user's quota.
And sometimes it's developer's
quota.
And when something is
run by a user, it's
using the user's quota.
So where do we draw
those lines?
And I think that we need
to draw this out.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I agree.
IKAI LAN: And if you have
anything else to add to make
that simpler for people.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
In general, it really depends
on whether you're publishing
your app as a user-authenticated
app, or an
anonymous-authenticated app,
which is running as yourself.
So, if you're sending emails in
that scenario, you'll have
to be really worried
about that limit we
talked about earlier.
So there's a multitude of user
cases that are now possible.
And we probably need a little
chart of saying, here's what
your impact is going to be.
Little sliders, and
knobs, and stuff.
IKAI LAN: Charts, charts.
All right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think we're
coming up on time.
Do we have time for one more?
IKAI LAN: We are just
running out of time.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Cool.
IKAI LAN: I'm getting
the signal.
So thank you all very much
for joining us today.
And, again, we will have Office
Hours next Thursday, as
well as next Tuesday is
a special session.
We'll be talking
about BigQuery.
And BigQuery, if you're not
familiar with BigQuery, it's a
way to take very large
data sets and do
SQL-like analysis on them.
And this is very useful.
This is built on a tool
that we use at
Google to do logs analysis.
We have lots and lots of logs.
And we need tools
to analyze them.
So the tool that we've
exposed is called
BigQuery, very cool tool.
Check that out.
I think you can find them under
cloud.google.com, or it
should link to it.
So check them out.
And if you want to learn more,
join us on Tuesday.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Thank you.
See you.
IKAI LAN: Thank you
all very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]